this is sal here again and i'm still
here with my good friend dr mahadevan
from stanford university and uh in the
last video we we had looked at adequacy
of x-rays which is for for the neck
which is you know is the x-ray good
enough but now let's assume we have good
x-rays now what do we look at uh the
next step is to look at the alignment so
we talk about the abcs abcs of reading a
cervical spine film and a starts with
adequacy that we went over yes and the
second part of a is
alignment okay so we're still in a
so now it's alignment okay i was
expecting something with the b all right
alignment
alignment
all right so this looks like this this
is about alignment this is about
alignment and there's four lines that we
look at
the first is the anterior vertebral body
line okay avbl right over there exactly
and basically what you're doing is
you're trying to draw a smooth line that
connects the anterior aspect the front
of all the vertebral bodies it should be
nice and smooth it's usually curved and
it all the points should sort of fit on
that line nothing should be off of that
line that would suggest that there was a
problem there i see an interior as you
just said means front exactly right
right okay
the next line is going to the back of
the vertebral body is the posterior
vertebral body okay so not the back of
the entire vertebrae
the vertebral body which is this boxy
part right in front exactly okay so
same thing
connecting a line up and down should be
nice and smooth as you've drawn it and
nothing should fall off that line though
no piece of that vertebral body should
fall off of the line you've drawn all
right sounds good and then
the next is we connect all the spinal
laminar junctions so this is the spinal
laminar line okay and it's where the
sort of the
the lamina connects to the spinous
process spinous process that sounds like
we can make a whole video about that
spanish process if you look at the back
of somebody's necks are those little
bumps that you can see okay uh and
that's the very best these triangular
things right here exactly okay
okay so you that you're just connecting
that line the kind of the front of these
triangles the base of these triangles so
to speak exactly okay and then the last
one and the last line is the spinous
process tips and again we're just
connecting the the top the tip of all
these spinous processes little the
little bony projections you can see if
you look at the back of somebody's neck
right right these two should generally
fall on a nice smooth curve right and so
the general rule if any of these don't
aren't aligned the way that we've drawn
it here it's it's a problem exactly
exactly we call it subluxation or mal
alignment or misalignment okay and these
are all uh suggest that there is a
problem there which is a big deal
because your spinal cord is going
through there absolutely if you look
between the two the green and the blue
line that's actually where your your
actual spinal cord runs right right
right down there exactly i see i see so
yeah you don't want that to get messed
up all right so let's let's look at a
few of these x-rays and see if we can if
any what anything's wrong or or if
there's something wrong if we can spot
it
actually now you know how to read
cervical spine x-rays i'm going to have
you look at the first x-ray okay let's
say
that's how i'm going to get sued for
malpractice let's see all right so
this one over here so let me just do the
first one let me let me just go what you
told me to do so i'm going to do it the
the anterior side of this vertebral body
exactly like i'm learning the words too
talking like a doctor okay so i'm gonna
draw a line here okay that looks pretty
good yep that looks decent
that was i'm i'm kind of let me see
this is still looks decent and
i don't know that that doesn't look
great does with this count i mean this
looks like a it got shifted over a
little bit absolutely huge it's not a
huge shifting but it's enough to that
it's it's not easy to draw so that i was
right you're absolutely right
yeah and in fact sometimes it's very
subtle and you picked up a very subtle
abnormality but again even though it's
subtle on the x-ray it could be serious
for the patient so you uh you
potentially save their spinal cord and
their lives by picking up an injury like
this okay good making me feel all right
very good okay so so that's just it's
literally something as subtle as that is
what you're looking for exactly again it
should be a nice smooth line or a nice
smooth curve and as you can see at that
junction it's no longer smooth now you
don't even have to look at the other
lines you just any one of these that you
don't align that's enough to say hey do
something else exactly and that's a
great important teaching point which is
if you see any abnormality on a plane
film on an x-ray like this you stop and
you protect their cervical spine and
then you get a more important study or a
better quality study like a ct scan
fascinating although if i do look here
it does look like we could have done the
the the pvbl and it looks like that also
is
is a little off too absolutely that one
and okay well let's get a few more great
i don't want to i don't want to focus
too much on my first victory
all right
so this is so it's clear that this
person is facing this way i can see
their teeth
so let's see let's see what we can do
here
okay can i give it a shot again please
okay please okay so let's um
the avbl it looks pretty good i mean
this this is
well that looks close it looks close i
agree and and it potentially again
you've got a you've got a very keen eye
and you might have picked it up but most
people might lift a gift you might say
you got to overlook that
so let's try let's try other the other
the other lines here so this is the
this is
okay so this one is more obvious
this one is more obvious that there's
kind of that disconnection right over
there exactly and this is the pvbl or
the posterior vertebral body line you
can see clearly
that line is not smooth it doesn't
connect and so there is a problem right
there at that junction okay okay all
right and so now we have this this this
last one right over here let me see what
i can do
let me see don't want to lose my streak
all right so
anterior side this actually looks pretty
perfect actually and in fact it is
perfect okay
um let me let me try the next lines here
this is the posterior vertebral body
line let me do that in a color that's
easier to see so let me do that i
already used orange i'll do magenta all
right so
this looks
looking
okay
looks okay that looks
okay i mean
yeah i mean nothing obvious on that line
i would say again you've got the keen
eye but in this particular case i'd say
it's fine yeah it's within the normal
range as well okay and so let me do the
the base of those triangles
let me do uh so this is a triangle right
over here
so that again you want to be a nice
smooth curve everything should fall on
that curve
so this
it would be i would have to be a little
bit generous with my curve to make it go
to
these guys down here exactly exactly
and this is the spinal laminar line
this is the third line of alignment as
you can see to try to get those to work
you could but they're not smooth like
the other lines and this is again
another subtle finding but
missing this finding because the first
two lines are normal could again be
devastating for the patient right right
and so you always want to err on the
side of caution i mean if anything looks
even a little bit suspicious maybe
another x-ray or yeah another x-ray
another view like we talked about before
or the definitive study is a ct scanner
computed tomography i see i see very
cool well thanks for this this is useful
my pleasure